[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
conscious machines we have dr. Yoshi
Bach joining us on the show hello hey
thanks so much for coming on really
appreciate it
I'm super excited for this after so this
is gonna be a really good one guys
dr. Yoshi Bach is VP of research at AI
foundation and author of principles of
synthetic intelligence he's focused on
how our minds work and how to build
machines that can perceive think and
learn and you can find the links below
in the bio to Bach AIB a-chii as well as
his LinkedIn and Twitter profiles all
right Yoshi let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world
I think we are right now at at the top
of the our world we are at the best
possible position to be born into and
imagine that you have the choice of
being born into a sustainable sane world
that is an agricultural society is 300
million people tops no internet nor
long-range transportation no interesting
educational system and so on right or
you can be in an insane world the world
it has just burned 100 million years
worth of trees in a single central me to
give everybody plumbing and access to
the world's knowledge is an afterthought
to a global chat whom to four point
distribution basically the internet
right and this is the thing that we have
right now it's an insane world but it's
the world in which we have computers in
which we can travel anywhere where we
can talk to a seven a half billion
people that are often very smart and
interesting and we are in the first time
in history on this planet of any
life-form I think in a situation if he
can meaningfully reflect the universe
this is a really amazing time to be
alive
it's really the best time to be alive so
in some sense you could see life on
Earth is this entropic puddle that is
more or less sustainable for a while
I mean 1/2 billion years then the
atmosphere will be gone and life on
Earth in its current form will cease to
exist and a few billion years later the
Sun will engulf the planet and I don't
think that will be a meaningful export
of life from this planet in an
intelligent form but might be who knows
probably not our species though we are
the first ones that basically made this
very short game to jump out of this
puddle as high as we can and we are
right now I think at the top of this
parabola and from here of course it will
go down again so people look down and
they freaked out they realized basically
we cantilevered ourselves over on
entropic abyss and there's no land on
the other side right can we come down it
will not be gentle but it was never nice
down there to begin with right you don't
want to be down there you want to have a
few generations up here if you your goal
is to understand what's going on in the
universe and if that is not your
preference if you want to have
sustainable volva that lack you didn't
get to make the choice these decisions
were made long ago I think the last
important bifurcation that we had was
when we opted in for the Industrial
Revolution and there was not much that
we could change that train on that
vehicle in the end and I'm very much in
favor of
trying to make a longer game and make it
more sustainable but it's quite likely
that we are unable to to return to a
sustainable state or that we are able to
make the present growth oriented
cancerous world sustainable right but
yeah you can look at this oh my god I'm
so depressed because the world is going
to go down from here or you can see it's
never been that high up right and we
wouldn't be talking if he wouldn't be in
this giant Titanic that is heading for
the iceberg okay excellent synthesis I
would do want to know how you know that
we are at the top of the parabola and
not how the how we're not just going to
continue going up on like a y equals x
just keep going up so typically when you
look at the way things happen right if
you see some kind of growth and if you
zoom out a little bit you see that it is
usually part of an s-curve that hits a
saturation point right and if you zoom
out even further you see that this is
going to come down because everything
that comes up tends to come down again
at some point and the question is where
you are right now and people tend to
extrapolate from the current direction
of the curve and not from the logical
dynamics of the overall curve and then
it becomes apparent that things are
flattening out or things might be going
down people go into denial because they
get invested in the present state of
affairs which looks like it's going up
we can arguably say that over the last
several million years that we've been
following an s-curve in terms of amount
of people amount of intelligence like
you said access to the world wealth of
knowledge on the Internet all these
great things longevity but why is it all
of a sudden going to go from this up in
the s-curve to a Down I think that for
the last few million years if you take
this perspective that was mostly not
many humans around right after the toga
eruption there were a few but a
population bottleneck was I think 7,000
people or so not that many ancestors
that we depend on they were probably
more people there but those people that
were successful and replaced everybody
was a small group back then and then we
were for a long time about a million
people a million you
beings roaming the planet and then the
invented agricultural societies and
probably religions to organize them and
so on and this got us through something
like 100 million people and at the turn
of the times when we had switched to
monotheistic religions we were at
something like 300 million people and we
stayed there for a long time there was
little growths and dips if we had a war
or some famine or a big disease and the
pandemic and then of pity at the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
we're still at something like 400
million and only Industrial Revolution
got us to billions of people the
modernist societies and now these
modernist societies have mostly
collapsed after World War two and we are
living in the aftermath of these
societies that have been created
basically in labs where people designed
the social systems that we are in that
are optimized for growth for feeding
large number of people living mass media
to coordinate them and so on and these
societies didn't invent good mechanisms
for error correction so there are
manifestly unstable which treats people
out right now okay so the instability of
the massive systems that are letting 8
billion of us play on this planet is one
of the reasons why you predict that this
curve goes down you could have put in
another way every organism that stays
around for a long time is playing a very
long game so the basically the fitness
function of the evolution needs to get
to all the individuals not just in every
generation but over many generations for
instance if you are a mouse and you live
in a complicated ecosystem you depend on
many many food species if you have food
scarcity what happens is the next
generation of mice is more sparse or
more scrawny and this happens for a few
generation so they don't over graze on
their environment so the species can
stick around the long term if the their
environment comes back and regrowth
right and we are now in the situation
that we have the choice of feeding our
children of having them being alive or
having civilization being alive and we
always pick our kids obviously right if
you have the choice of having your
children die or having civilization die
in the long run you want your children
to have a good life you
want to make them Val FET you want to be
them to be healthy to be educated they
should have a good house they should
have access to friends and computer
games and so on and because we are
always confronted with this choice and
individually we are basically unable to
constrain ourselves in such a way that
he owed over grace our resources yes we
don't seem to have a force that would
constrain us but at the same time we are
heading in to a large degree towards the
abundance of being able to grow our own
things like meat and leather and all
these other interesting ways of being
able to sustain more effectively on the
planet sequester carbon a confusion for
energy so it's just how is it that we
have either kids or long-term
civilization what why can't it be both
providing for children and having long
terms of listen I think it might be
possible but it's not going to be all
roses if we would be doing this we
probably would have to submit to an
organizing principle that is extracting
a heavy toll from us I mean it's
conceivable that we create some AI
dictatorship that organizes is us in
such a way that we live in a few
population control habitats and we can
outlive our days as a species and
relative peace and harmony basically
some kind of people zoo but if that
people self organize we are very much
like orcs that overrun the environment
and eat everything in that path and then
we think about how to make this
sustainable we tend to focus on this
these few ideas carbon sequestration is
an excellent example the reason why all
this carbon is in the atmosphere all
this carbon dioxide is because by
burning the carbon and into carbon
dioxide we got the fuel that build in
that civilization in the first place the
reason why we have seven health billion
people living in relative comfort is
because we burned all this carbon and
put it there
so basically we are running on the depth
and paying back this depth was never in
the cards and a carbon sequestration
would mean basically we would need to
use a multiple of that energy - without
a business case to get all this carbon
out of the atmosphere again and buried
in the ground the way in which it does
not escape and we are still burning
carbon that we get out of the ground
right we are still doing this so the
easiest way of
and sequestration would be to stop
burning any carbon at all and especially
not getting new ones out of the ground
and we don't do this so I think it's a
pipe dream that's wishful thinking okay
okay we are very good at this for
thinking it's an interesting phenomenon
to observe and it's also nothing to be
upset about right it's just how people
are like you said the organizing
principles are the things that can keep
propagating the s-curve up if we can
galvanize together and make these code
changes within our social dynamics okay
if you have something that has unlimited
growth it hits a singularity at some
point right it's there is no system that
remains stable without symmetries okay
all right this is a excellent intro to
the episode all right let's do the
journey so okay born in Germany loved
computer science and AI growing up in
philosophy as well and then you ended up
doing your PhD in cognitive science you
spent some time in New Zealand this will
also teach us about how you were growing
up and how you even got interested in
these fields well I grew up in some
somewhat insane society communist
eastern Germany had burnt the down its
civilization alive mind so to speak
every philosophy was replaced by a very
vulgar version of materialist Marxist
dialectic and everything that your
teachers told you seemed to be at least
to me to my little nerd mind insane and
unbelievable like not even the
mathematics was correct I felt as a
child and I grew up as a child of an
artist in the forest so basically if
farewell in a big cave full of books and
then I ventured out into the world after
having already read too many books
I met went to school it was worth for
eight years then I went to a mathematics
school then I saw that how what real
mathematics looks like and then I
decided that it's possible to make sense
of the world but I would have to do it
by myself
but to understand the meaning of a
statement what it actually means that
something is true or not true in some
sense you have to go full circle right
you have to go down to the foundations
and to make this journey to the
foundations that's in some sense my
journey
it's very hard to make this right as an
autonomous intellect most of the
autonomous intellects don't get very far
and I probably don't get very far either
whenever I heaven
tremendous insight and typically like
400 years late to the party but I
discovered that these parties become
more interesting and obscure the smaller
parties know that I discovered at the
same time there are the big parties
right there large groups of people that
share ideas and these large groups of
people that share ideas they are often
not right because the principles by
which people get to consensus are often
not tools oriented right so individual
minds often get it right and groups like
if they agree on the thing that's not
likely to be true like the scientific
consensus on arbitrary topics is
naturally something that is going to
change like there was a for a long time
and consensus about nutrition and you
now know it's it's basically all wrong
and how is that possible and it's I
think if you're for instance programmers
realize it's impossible for us to even
agree about simple things like which
programming use for which kind of
project it's very hard to do this and if
you have a consensus about complicated
questions more complicated than this you
need a force that builds consensus and
this force is probably not who's
oriented by consensus orient it's a
political force right so people if they
are thinking groups tend to believe
things for political reasons not because
they are true
so we have to find this balance we have
to figure out to which degree to have
people proper epistemology and this
question of epistemology is in some
sense the foundation of our thinking you
should have all the possible beliefs but
shift evidence shape the confidence of
according to the evidence on them right
so we can only believe something to the
degree that we have evidence for it that
it's possible that this is supported by
something yeah
belief should not be a verb it's not
related to us we should not be
identified with our beliefs you should
only be directed by tools we don't get
better people if you believe the right
thing or worse people if you believe the
wrong things Nika just thinks that we
are looking at models in our mind that's
jump into this that's okay yeah let's do
it this it totally actually gave me a
bunch of light bulbs when we were
talking about who you are how you became
who you are yeah when you were jogging I
was like wow this makes more sense along
the way you actually ended up moving to
Cambridge as well doing some time at MIT
Media Lab and Harvard evolutionary
dynamics before coming out here yeah
well just quick what was the spark that
got you to move from Germany to
Cambridge in the United States well I
studied computer science and philosophy
I found that philosophy was not as
useful as I hoped and only later I
learned that this was because of the
state philosophy and academia is in
right now it's mostly a simulation of
the real thing it's very hard to get
paid for via philosophy you typically
get paid if you are a philosopher for
being part of a particular culture of
talking like a philosopher reading like
a philosopher citing like a philosopher
and publishing like a philosopher is
very hard to do actual philosophy on the
side the intellectual progress you're
not incentivized to do that and so more
interesting progress I think happens in
more foundational fields like computer
science where people have a formal
education and study of psychology and
physics and so on and then I did my PhD
in cognitive science and I found it hard
to fit into the academic system as it
was because was lodging mostly
interested in applying methods and not
so much in answering the questions that
I had
and so I started a few companies and
co-founded them then I got an
opportunity to work at MIT which I
jumped on and so I spent some time in
the US and now I got an offer to join an
amazing team in San Francisco called
AI foundation they can work on some of
my ideas on how to model motivation and
emotion in more detail yep
in the motivation and emotion of how we
perceive the world as well as how
machines will perceive the world is of
central key to what we're gonna be
discussing now so alright let's jump
into it we have some awesome visuals to
show you guys along the way okay so we
find ourselves in the 3d world in the
physical world what is the relationship
between the physical world and our minds
so it's all question right so you could
first of all start out with this idea of
what is access to the world when I was
sitting in front of my first computer a
comment over 60 fear for and about 1983
I looked at the screen and I realized
that everything that I can think of can
be displayed on a screen if I really
know how to think about it right I can
write a program that produces an
arbitrary pattern on the screen
everything that I perceive is some kind
of pattern
so in some sense my access to the world
the universe out there is to suit am
kind of screen and that's we might be my
retina or might Alamos and my brain is
making sense of this and to understand
the world I need to understand what a
pattern generator looks like that is
responsible for producing those patterns
so we can ask ourselves what kind of
computer do we need to produce the
patterns that we observe right and it
could be a discrete state machine like
my Commodore 64 bits a finite amount of
memory or it could be probabilistic
state machine that randomly goes from
state to state or has a certain degree
of randomness in there or it could be
some quantum computer over every state
it's a superposition of a ground state
right or it could be one of these
versions but this infinite memory number
four is basically our discrete state
machine with infinite memories our ultra
and the Turing machine
this mathematical formalization of
modern computer or we could take the
perspective of physics which mostly
thinks that the universe is geometric
which means things move continuously
inners in there is at some this at the
time level infinite resolution and it
could also be that it's even an a course
or have a computer so there could be
closed timelike loops so information
could be sent back and time all these
are in some sense mathematical
possibilities but what we have
discovered is that there is a difference
between mathematics and computation
mathematics is the domain of all
languages in which you can specify
things and computation is the part that
can be implemented and there's something
that was discovered earlier in the 20th
century basically Hilbert saw some
inconsistencies
especially after looking counter sets
they were even came to infinities to
infinite sets and the total set and he
discovered we have a problem semantics
of mathematics in the way we define
truth and we define what is true at all
please mathematicians fix our meta
mathematics and so they went to work and
girdle came back and said I have bad
news we cannot really build a computer
in mathematics that doesn't break while
running the semantics of mathematics
oh we have uh there's a question about
your thoughts on psychedelics from the
audience
meet me maybe we should just take a
quick I think that psychedelics will X
your priors which means they're more
things that you consider to be true when
you are in psychedelics apparently and
as a result you can make inferences that
you otherwise could not make but which
are largely wrong
so it basically it's academics might
have people to escape local minima in
the belief space and it's the same
purpose I think what dreams have and I
suspect that psychedelics are very
similar to lucid dreaming and the
functionality escaping local minimum
beliefs yeah yeah that's good stuff yeah
but sometimes yes the paths that can be
wrong the thing that you enter in does
not have to be a better belief it can be
one that is fundamentally more loopy
especially if you fall in love with it
and don't escape that many more McGann
yeah yeah yeah yeah because we can
become attached to that idea and then
yeah correct versus continuing to have
an open mind okay yeah yes good one so
curing also worked on this problem the
same one that good worked on and he
discovered that the same problem right
tools is defined by a proofs in
mathematics something is to if you can
prove it and a proof is the reduction of
a statement to axioms is basically a
form of data compression and compress
the statement to the axioms and the
value do this is you apply a procedure
and mathematics is defined in a timeless
fashion so you can use infinite many in
many steps to get there and what Google
at your own discovered is that you
cannot use infinitely many steps because
nobody can do this right nothing can do
this you cannot make the claim that
something is true and you cannot
actually get that in order to actually
get there you can only you have finitely
many steps which means you have to
redefine truth into something where you
actually show the money they actually
show how to get for
your axioms to the proof in the finite
number of steps so you in this sense PI
for instance is not a value high is a
function you can run this function gives
you new didyou digits until your local
Sun burns out and this is it but you can
never have a computation that depends on
knowing the last digit of pi and it's
interesting that a lot of physics
behaves as if you could because physics
basically checked out this whole library
from mathematics without reading the
comments especially the more recent ones
that were done in the first half of the
20th century so basically the part of
mathematics that works is constructive
mathematics is this thing that you can
implement it's computation which means
of course we can build a causal hyper
computer in some sense a computer that
can send information back in time we
just do this by freezing this universe
state then running a copy of the
universe into the future taking that
information and merging it into the
present state and continuing right so in
some sense you can do this you can not
have a continuous universe but you can
have one that is arbitrarily quasi
continuous that gets as close to
continuity as you want and on the level
of it where we interact then always too
many things to count so if you squint
it's almost like infinite so if we look
at these computations of how many parts
behave in the limit which means they're
almost continuous but if you zoom in you
realize it's still integers it's still
discrete there is still only finite
amounts of computer information being
moved around in finite amounts of time
so in some sense we can use computation
as a metaphor this ability of a system
to go from state to state
there's the transition function it's a
deterministic one if it's the same on
every time an inter monistic one if it's
a different one every time we can use
this to understand all the pattern
generators the computer can produce
observables but we can also build minds
that observe these principles and do
anything that's computable it there is
make any kind of model so basically all
Commodore 64 is enough if you give me
enough memory
it's a very interesting question about
quantum computers of course because
quantum computers have been around the
corner for at least half a century and
you haven't gotten quite there yet and
it's interesting question why that is
why is it that we haven't gotten quite
there yet is it because their
formalization of quantum mechanics it is
not completely computable and it's only
approximately true or is it because of
something else because there's too much
noise in there maybe there is no
continuous space underlying the whole
thing and the non-local things create
too much noise or another way of looking
at the whole thing is that the premise
of quantum mechanics is that our
particle universe is inefficiently
implemented on the underlying substrate
if the particle universe is really
efficiently implemented we can harvest
the computation of the underlying
substrate like imagine you live in
Minecraft and you are officially
implementing the CPU then you cpu is
only polynomial times faster than you
are right so you cannot build a computer
in Minecraft that is going to be faster
than the normal computations are my
craft a classical minecraft operations
even if you use the CPU you are only
going to be faster by some polynomial
amount of time but if minecraft was
inefficiently implemented if it's super
slowly implemented on the CPU visit
minecraft you wouldn't notice but if you
could somehow harvest the computation
under that is underneath it even if it's
a classical one it would be more than
polynomial fast with respect to the
computers that we can make from
minecraft particles right so this is the
interesting question basically is our
universe efficiently implemented or
inefficiently implemented but it's still
going to be computational ok so let's go
back a step and let's think about what's
our relationship to the universe what's
the relationship between mind and
universe right and so the traditional
that was an interesting process for the
first question oh man holy cow there's
it's very evident that you've taken a
lot of time to synthesize these fields
together in
what you're presenting to us now okay
all right so basically the idealist
position that you'll find in many
Eastern religions for instance and it's
the one that we live in a dream right
the reality that we perceive is not
mechanical there is something else going
on it's a dream in which magic is
possible in which you can have
precognition in which you can perform
rituals that change the course of the
planets and human destiny and so on in
which astrology works all these things
are only explainable not to pay us not
living in a mechanical universe but in a
dream universe that is dreamt by them my
higher mind but by a mind on a higher
plane of existence right so you can have
these symbolic interactions you make
this ritual sacrifice and as a result
your life changes how is that possible
yeah this is something that we can't
basically only explain by accepting that
you live in a dream if you think that is
real you could also say we have a
dualist situation where your mind and
universe are basically separate
computers that interacts to an interface
so we have our computational mind that
is making sense of the world and the ad
that's right we have our computational
universe and the typical position that
we have right now and our Western world
is a modest position very basically your
universe gives you the computations on
which you have your mind run basically
the part of the universe that runs your
mind is the brain and on that brain
computer we generate interpretations of
what's happening in the outside world
the observed about some kinds of of
observational interface like our retinas
and cochlea and so on and the surface
our body okay and why is this mono
monism because it's only one thing there
is not a mind world and a material world
but it's all the material world right
it's all this primary substrate in which
we exist in a monocle so basically
materialist monism says the universe is
mechanical and everything that happens
in your mind is part of that mechanism
okay
and what I would suggest is a small
correction or a small change to this
perspective I think that these positions
are of materialism Manas materialism and
modest idealism so you only have dreams
and you only have the material world
actually in some sense complimentary I
think that you need to exist in the
dream but it's a dream that is being
dreamt and the brain of a private uni
right and this primate lives in the
physical universe so the mind of the on
the higher plane of existence is in
physics physics is the higher plane of
existence the reason by previous
civilizations were largely not
interested in describing this higher
plane of existence is because they
didn't have devices to play with physics
or because they didn't have social
technology and by which it philosopher
could change the feudalist agricultural
society that ever living in and they
were not putting much emphasis on this
right if you don't get along with the
world as it is you need to change the
way you perceive it you need to change
your motivations you need to change the
way you generate your dream of the world
in your place in it and if you adjust
this you will usually find or you're not
but you are as fine as you can be under
the circumstances right so basically you
focus on this inner world on how you
generate your perception of reality and
these techniques and this is something
that we largely don't do in the West our
Western rationality was largely leave
the mind alone and instead if you don't
like something change reality so we
focus on this outside world and we
neglect the way our perception is
generated and a lot of people even a lot
of Western philosophers are
fascinatingly unaware of the fact that
we live in the dream that the same
circuits that makes dreams at night they
make it ring you on the day only the
dream during the day is tuned to protect
your sensory patterns right so it's a
model that we make what is the model
when we're in our dream space and when
we're in our awake space we are running
we're using same neural architecture
with within ourselves for both of those
situations
yet there is a in the in the physical
world there is a a
there is a this this machine made from
neurons
and there's there's a a you called it a
is a tree a dream a dream state that
were in in the body of a primate
yes but the monism is that it's all in
the in this oh it's basically only a
mechanical universe and the mechanical
universe creates emergent patterns but
VR is real as a character in a novel you
and me are characters in the multimedia
novel that is being authored by the
brain
dharmaiah movie yeah star of our own
movies all of us yeah but all star of
our own movies are starved collective a
collective movie there is no way you can
get out of the individual dream a
collective as part of your dream it's
not that other Minds tell you what to do
you interpret a part of the universe of
the patterns that you see on your retina
as being emanations of other people
other minds are your invention
other minds are my invention yes you the
degree that you can perceive my mind
that you construct a model of it that
you think I'm a sentient being that you
can interact with
but this interaction takes place
entirely in your own mind yes
okay yeah this is so much yeah there's
no way to make a stream and ever you
find yourself immersed in a reality you
are in a trance State but you basically
take some representation and think you
are inside of that it's a similar trance
to when you see a movie right when you
see a movie you suspend your disbelief
and you are that cowboy that sees the
Wild West and you right along the
Prairie and then suddenly the light goes
on and realize oh my god this is all not
true I'm in a different reality now
right and you cannot wake up from that
one at least
you cannot wake up from it without
losing what makes you human
what makes lets you make sense of the
world and there's an airship of the MA
my ability to change the way that I
perceive versus changing a physical
world that was one of the points that
you made so we can kind of upgrade our
own perception of reality and the way
that we engage with the reality that
were embedded in versus trying to
necessarily change that physical yes
it's often also very necessary that you
become aware of that right for instance
if you have self-hatred you will
perceive that the universe is mean to
you that you're experiencing many ways
ways that the universe treats you badly
and you also treat yourself badly
because part of your software does not
worry you buy into you it thinks the
thing that you are is very flawed and
should not really be supported right so
if you don't like yourself you are going
to punish yourself at some sense which
means your mind is going to create a
simulation in which reality treats
yourself badly and this book sometimes
lead to bad outcome sometimes might lead
to better ones there is a reason why
your mind thinks that's the best setup
but this perception that you are aware
of reality is virtual this
identification that you have is your
beliefs and your experience is something
that's generated inside of your mind
it's basically like a groove that is
full through a record in a record player
and the record is the groove of your
life and you're being pulled through
this and when you dream you can put this
groove into something else or when you
are in the second
State like our friend here us mm-hmm
right and so this identification because
what you feel what you experience in
some sense it's your it can become your
choice you can become responsible for
this so I can I can simulate a
self-hatred state or it can simulate a
self-love state yes and so upgrading my
perception is upgrading the way that I
shoot at which I sit which I simulate
which is which I collapse into my
reality you could also get to a neutral
state in which you realize that all
these evaluations that you put on the
area you think that you are super
lovable or super flawed are actually not
helpful or not truthful and you just are
you're just a physical system and you're
not in the category of things that has
the ability to be adequate or inadequate
you just exist and you deal with that
okay good so how do we make models and
model is basically a set of variables
things that can change into
relationships between them the
relationships are the things that don't
change in variances right they the
relation between the different variables
is for instance the laws of perspective
they don't change in the world that
mutually exists that's an invariance and
the laws of perspective dictate if I see
your nose and your nose points in a
particular direction which is a free
variable it predicts the position of
your face your face would point in the
direct same direction as your nose
otherwise I'm looking at something
that's impossible
so this relationship are in some sense
they are possible istic and the world
that we are in is not a probable it's a
possible world even if a tiger comes up
to you and it's not probable it would
still be possible to represent this
right and we will always try to find an
interpretation of our sense of my
patterns that is possible where every
feature that we perceive is compatible
according to the relationship that we've
learned to all the others but in order
to to get there we need to learn
probability because there are infinitely
many possible States or almost
infinitely many and so when we see a
bunch of patterns after we wake up in
the morning we need to converge on one
of these possible states so we know that
your nose being pointed certain ways
where your face is gonna be pointed with
almost a hundred percent yes see almost
if not then we have to learn that their
prognosis so we will put our attention
on this thing where we have this
inconsistency and we will try to resolve
it and this means usually the extent the
model and this is largely how we learn
we discover in consistencies in our
models and then the extent that ok by
adding new relationships or modifying
existing ones right and if we have a
model that already works most of the
time then we need a way together to
converge to what we currently perceive
the pattern that the urban environment
need to be interpreted with the
particular kind of models so we get this
model state by following probability the
probability tells you if I see the
following patterns it's likely that the
following model should apply and I
should interpret the world in this
particular way and these links are
responsible for instance for optical
illusions they're shortcuts that make us
see the world in a particular way even
though it might be different but it
helps you to speed up your convergence
to a particular state that's why we have
many of these solutions and then we have
the Preferences they give color to all
perception right it's not just all
meaningless interesting structured
patterns it's there's something going on
that is relevant to us that because it
can give us pleasure and pain and these
preference relationships they tell us
how certain things deviate from a target
instead of just measuring them
absolutely right so and in some sense
this measurement that is not absolute
but relative is an identification where
you think something should be like this
instead of it yes it's like this and
this is where we could say within the
model there are motivations yes and the
motivations guide us towards the
preference yes and the preference means
you are a system that wants to change
these things towards that preference so
when you feel pain you might have a
preference to make that pain end and in
some sense it's the nature of that pain
right or if you feel that you live in a
world that is not just you might feel a
pain that directs you on making it more
just and you identify with this you
realize I am a system that is directed
on making the world more just and it is
some imposition on the world that you
make and it might be a good one you
might have good outcomes
it might also be that the dress world
never existed and wouldn't even burn
but it's the commitment that your mind
makes that you should perceive the world
in particular where the world should be
different than it is in this sense that
the world should be different than it is
that's the purpose of the existence of
our mind is to help the organism to
regulate for its evolutionary needs and
when we are when we are born into the
world do we have within us already the
DNA for the preferences and for the
motivations for what our character
decides is the thing that's our North
Star at or some degree I think so I have
found that in my own children after
they're born they had very strong
preferences and eventually what became
more detail was not the preferences but
their ideas their own ideas of what
exactly the preferences are and how to
realize them and that largely depends on
the environment but I suspect that the
things that make you happy or unhappy
are things that are determined in Italy
in the organism yeah and also makes
sense right because motivation is not
adaptive its resistive motivation is how
you resist physics and society and
everything else it's not to give in just
put us all into a puddle on the ground
it's where you push against reality
it's very regulate so it needs to be
innate cannot be adaptive
we're running within us the motivations
that we want to adapt will change our
perception but also as well in the
reality that we live in with what we
want to do in that reality how we want
to change that reality towards those
motivations that's perfect but of course
we can learn to change this to some
degree we can learn to dis identify with
certain conversion things but it's hard
and it typically happens relatively late
in our life yes yes okay
so basically the control of this
organism starts miss feedback loops and
they're implemented and now a brain stem
or a brick Tilly inside so to speak so
there are lots of feedback loops that
regulate your breathing patterns heart
rate your body movements and so on and
as soon as it becomes so complicated
that it cannot be done automatically it
you create models of this in your
neocortex and in between you have these
identifications where you shoot so this
is what this is autonomic nervous system
bleeding heart rate yeah yeah yeah but
you can make all these things you can
submit them to your own control and you
usually do so when they automatic
regulation fails then you will spawn
some cortical process that takes care of
regulating your reality so the most
primordial feedback loops are at the
most limbic I think that we made
available here at the brain stem because
they have the potential that I need to
be regulated for instance if you your
health becomes fragile you might need to
pay attention to your heart rate and you
can learn how to regulate your heart
rate but as long as that's not necessary
because you're autonomous regulation of
the heart rate is perfect you unaware of
your heart rate and I suspect it happens
for almost all the things you whenever
your feedback loops are a sufficient you
don't need to pay attention and you
don't need to run dots of particle
computations on it and the attention is
necessary to create new mental processes
that then become automated and as soon
as they are automatic you usually don't
spend attention on them anymore
yes which means you cannot remember them
then oh you're not no longer conscious
of them right I mean if we want to
remember we need to go through the
process of yeah going through that yet
tedious remember thank you how to do
that so the limbic system is in some
sense implementing a machine of
motivation where you have social and
cognitive and physiological needs and
they all compete yes and they create
afferent pleasure and pain signals and
when we act we don't just act on
pleasure and pain we act on models of
them which you could call purposes and
these needs don't form a hierarchy they
just coexist and compete they don't form
a hierarchy no needs just coexist they
might be have different strengths but
there are people that
might starve because they serve
political goals or because the children
are more important to them right it's
not that you first solve existential
safety and then you do the revolution or
then you do the art it might be that you
do this all at the same time and you
just get drawn to these things and
different proportions and depending on
the opportunity and the relative
strengths of the need at a given moment
you are more drawn to this on water on
to that but when you want to coordinate
your life you need to make models of
them you need to understand concepts
like survival survival except I don't
think it's a need too complicated right
you need to understand this no in order
to understand survival death is a
complicated concept it was difficult to
understand for my children to remember
when they realized Oh some organisms
stopped moving at some point and all
people at some point they're no longer
around and this will also happen to me
and it's something that happens
relatively late it's not in the first
few months but in the first few months
you already have pain avoidance and some
sense of existential safety and so on
you're only combine this into a purpose
of survival then you are able to form
the model and these purposes they need
to form a hierarchy so they become
accountable to each other and this
hierarchy has different solutions in
different people so in some sense the
shape of your soul is the hierarchy of
your purposes and the top node is
usually not the ego the ego is just a
function that integrates the expected
reward over the next 50 years or so and
the really interesting functions are
above that where you serve long ranging
purposes and this allows us to cooperate
because we serve serve shared purposes
mm-hmm yes I think that's at the core of
this altruistic love is the discovery of
shared purpose and others yes so the
North Star that we find most meeting in
doing every single day
it usually transcends our own ego
towards the shared purpose yes we also
realize your ego is just a lot of work
why do you keep it up right there needs
to be an underlying purpose to make that
necessary you need to be a relatively
stupid to think everything is only
important for your ego because you're
not thinking very far because you're not
getting much out of the ego ultimately
it's not creating that much pleasure to
have an ego
gosh this part is such a mixed bag of
motivations even right their cognitive
physiological and social that's a huge
mixed bag and however we end up
determining what the next step is is a
huge mystery at times yeah yeah I
suspect it gets more boring when you
figure it all out right you always know
what the next step is yeah yeah it
definitely gets more boring if is it
well if you you know hopefully when we
run the simulations we can gain more
insight through these processes and yeah
looks like we're yeah already
potentially in an 80 year process of
levelling up some character yeah yeah
imagine you had an Allen simulation that
tells you always what your next step is
that out models you and thinks a few
steps ahead and tells you these are your
options and this is the one that you're
going to pick and this is the one that
you should be picking yeah we can
potentially visualize that even right
now right well yeah what is the next
best option yeah correct and to be able
to be in a state of constantly engaging
with that yes it's beautiful yeah but
it's also it can be it takes all the
mystery away yeah yeah yeah okay
neurons live in to do this do I be
typically think about how to impose the
bill of the mind on matter so when you
think about how Minsky built a I had an
idea of how things work and then you
implement this as an algorithm the place
chess or that's whatever right and now
if you live in the second phase of AI
where we have systems that discover the
solution to a problem so we give a
problem and thus function that helps the
system out valid tasks on the problem to
the algorithm and the algorithm figures
out how to implement this solution but
it's still a very top-down centralized
control and/or when your words are doing
it very differently every there is no
centralized control in the brain because
everything has to be implemented as
individual cells the cell is the
smallest unit there from some
perspective
and also take different ones where it's
even smaller and it's molecules within
the cells right but if you take the cell
it's this smallest unit of compression
then you have your neuron and then your
own in some sense it lives in the
darkness it's it's a small animal that
tries to get fat and they link up
it's a embryonal neurons in the petri
dish and they try to find connections to
each other and they try to learn which
signals in the environment predict
anticipated rewards so which which
signals they should fire on to get fed
in return and this is we have sense all
day to October mean is our reward so uh
eventually dopamine is globally for the
brain responsible for reward it also has
a few other local worlds I suspect what
happens is that the brain can is very
good at making a few thousand chemicals
some of these chemicals are can be very
quickly exchanged some of them more
slowly and it uses them as a language
and the words of this language one of
these words is dopamine this molecule
they mean something different in
different contexts when you for instance
use a dopaminergic drug like Advil
it often interacts with other system you
use the same language so in a stratum
dopamine means something different than
in the prefrontal cortex and as a result
it might get more control but you also
get more tics
right so it's because it's not one thing
it's just a particular kind of language
that is being spoken between the neurons
here but they from the individual
neurons some of them are more to nergic
neurons and they get rewarded by acting
on serotonin yes yes ok ok and then
they're moving towards what it brings
the highest reward towards the
motivation the preferences basically
your neurons will learn whatever you
feed them for whatever you feed them for
yes so the your organism is setting up
the brain in such a way that the neurons
get fed if they're regulate what you
want to regulate if if the if the
the trajectory that I'm collapsing is in
the area of self-doubt pity sadness
disparity cetera that there's gonna be a
feedback system within my brain in that
direction versus collapsing towards self
love care harmony with others so so
there's there is a neurological process
that's occurring with the the way that
neurons are firing and wiring together
yes but this is already super high level
and there are many predefined circuits
with respect to controlling your social
interactions and so on and if you don't
have certain priors built inside of your
brain you're probably not going to
figure this out there high functioning
autistic people that are not very social
because they didn't start out with the
same priors and their life was not long
enough to converge to the same optimum
as other people did and then it's also
the question is it an optimum yeah
correct is this very deserving the
individual or the species or whatever
it's directing that evolution optimally
yes and it's something that you can only
see when you zoom very far out yeah so
but on the lowest level for instance
neurons try to predict the patterns in
their environment and react on them and
so the way we perceive reality I think
can be understood like a synthesizer
okay so for instance when you get
signals coming in from your cochlea you
don't take the frequencies of sound
because the neurons cannot oscillate at
20 kilohertz and you weren't like to
oscillate at something like 20 Hertz so
you first decompose the sound into a
different energy spectrum and you have
little hairs and you snake like organ or
it's nail like organ in your inner ear
and they react depending on the energy
of the sound at different frequencies
and they sent this to the brain and the
brain is now trying to make sense of
these patterns and it makes sense of
these patterns by being able to predict
them so when the sound starts it tries
to continue the sound to know what's
happening next and when it does this
it's able to explain it so you can do
this very similar to a synthesizer you
have a few knobs and you have an
oscillator and there's some almost
random connection which of circuits and
you tune them until you get this
you want and when you are used to your
particular synthesizer you get pretty
good at this right and you don't only do
this for sound but you can also do this
for vision so you look for spatial
frequencies for colors and so on and you
but lots and lots of synthesizers in
your brain that are able to predict and
continue these patterns once they start
occurring and once they're are done with
training and they don't get better you
combine the synthesizers and try to find
the meta patterns the patterns in the
patterns and across different modalities
and so you find for instance percepts
you realize that different sounds are
related by pitch you can explain a
family of sounds by just changing the
pitch between them or the loudness you
get a new method and ultimately you get
some thing very unify all the
simulations and you know all the
percepts in your mind and what you get
is a cohesive simulation where
everything moves around in three
dimension space because it's a simple
explanation that we can find for the
things that are going on on our cochlea
and a field of vision okay so we have a
both auditory input and visual input
here though I'm telling tactile input as
well but so what you're what you're
explaining is that we have a way with
our our auditory senses to slowly build
layers of strut that give us something
then visually same thing build layers
that give us something yes and then we
smash even these together to give us
this yes moving until you get a unified
model of the world and it's basically
the biggest and soft task in AI have to
do this unified model of the world
instead of having a bunch of classifiers
that react to individual feature
complexes in the world learn everything
into a single function into one universe
and this is what we're able to do right
you you try to make sense of the
universe and one function there's one
way in which the reality works yeah yeah
yeah and it's such a beautiful thing
here that is able to take in yeah all of
the different senses and create that
model but with AI this is the grand
challenge
of the grass it's basically the way two
of us to think about this and take this
to the next level in some sense there
because make a step realization of a
mind is understanding its own nature
it's understanding how we work and AI is
the best chance that we have in finding
it out by making testable theories and
to be able to take in that much more
information and compute on all that is
creatively run all the permutations I
mean that's like a massive holy grail
for for advancing us and yeah okay this
is great
square in charge anyway like who's who's
in charges AI yo show thoughts our own
AI or which AI just as the AI in AI we
trust the the AI that is gonna become
our God our government you mean like in
Game of Thrones so who's in charge of
the AI that becomes the super
intelligence who's in charge of the
super star it's a interesting open
question I mean how can we know now it's
difficult to predict things especially
when they are in the future and so why
should it be who like a human being at
the moment we typically put a single
human being at the top of a company or
of a state and I think that is for a
particular reason okay it's not obvious
right why don't you have a team to run
for president you mean yeah as if an
individual would be able to achieve
anything without having the right team
right if you have the wrong team you're
not going to achieve anything on any
circumstances it's complicated and so
the team really makes you feel sure but
why is that this individual and I think
it's because if you have a system that
has very complex walls we cannot really
express this well as an algorithm it's
too brittle it's too easy to get this
wrong and if you have a committee if you
have a group that makes the decisions
you basically need to come down to walls
of compromise and so on
and the worlds are not always the best
solution right if you think every
decision should be done by voting
between a group of individuals that USSD
act with a certain function you will
discover their circumstances where this
was not the best solution the and it
doesn't mean that there's an alternative
it is always the best solution so the
edge of what you need to do if you want
to put the system in a particular
direction
eventually they need to be implemented
in a single mind because the single mind
is right now the most complicated
information processing system that is
completely integrated with itself it
makes sense of the world in particular
way that we have so in some sense France
in the German elections are about not
just having party politics betting at
other countries rather but by finding
the best German the most German German
of of their generation and the results
are mixed a little bit but most Germans
think that is largely successful so in
some sense and gala Merkel is the most
German German of her generation from
from some particular perspective and she
embodies where this country should go
and she's the one that ultimately makes
a lot of the decisions not all the
details and out of checks and balances
and oversight and many boards and so on
but this main direction that you cannot
express all in rules and codes of
conduct and so on they need to be
implemented in a single individual and
in a sense and when we give everything
to an AI the question is do we do this
right is this thing or do we need to
have a human envelope and if you do this
are we going to increase the fallacy of
this human being like we did in German
fascism but that we have a tightly
control system that removes a lot of the
redundancy makes the system extremely
powerful and effective but if this guy
at the top it is insane horrible things
happen mm-hmm so this is the same
dangers a of course how can you make
sure that you're not accidentally
implementing something that you would
think is insane and what is sane right
yes is it not insane to wake up in a
monkey mm-hmm and it's not a nice monkey
it's a pretty violent here from the
perspective of basically every other
species aspect maybe the parasitic
species that parasitize on humans like
dogs and cats and so on
we are pretty wild but trees probably
don't like us very much
yeah yeah there again there's just so
many good things I really appreciated
how you said that there's a time when
there's an optimal function for the
dynamically adjusting system that can
see when it's best for a team to step up
and handle something versus an
individual to step up and handle
something or the collective to handle
something there's the adjusting of a
super intelligence to be able to handle
things like that and just like the
governance structures of today's
civilization but yeah is it insane to
wake up in a monkey suit yes it is very
and sayd wake up in a monkey suit why
aren't we waking up in other things yet
well maybe we will create the substrates
that enable us to walk I wake up and
different suits a dolphin rod wants to
wake up in a dolphin look for a couple
hours couple days you know a lifetime a
lifetime yeah yeah I want to bounce
between like Eagle octopus I want to go
outside of this universe to other
designer universes that are not like
this one that are not governed in this
way this is good story about Mulla
Nasreddin Hodja an aspirin some Sufi
mystic that may have existed at some
point and he is going to a bank and he's
being asked to identify himself and he
pulls out his mirror and he looks in the
mirror and says it seems to be me yeah
[Laughter]
what do you recognize when you see in
the mirror yeah what is that thing what
is it that you are exactly yes it's
great question great question
so maybe there is nothing there and it's
maybe there is nobody in charge maybe
it's an emergent thing that invents
every moment a new person to be in
charge and that person thinks it's you
because it believes it says memories
physio to upload you it's very simple
just make a machine that thinks it's you
some of your friends might disagree but
just upload them to Iran definitely
feels that way yeah so we were at the
neurons the neurons form columns the
columns of honcho approximates that talk
to each other basically humans form
small teams that because they discover
that they are better at anticipating
reward how to get fit if they form these
teams and organizational units yes and
there's a process that you're not able
to replicate yet so the algorithms that
our machines are implementing right now
are much more you could say primitive
but maybe not primitive thought top-down
or bottom-up and it's very hard to think
bottom-up has many moving parts it's
much easier for us to think top-down in
terms of control not of emergent control
we kind of do the same thing in society
as human that is a neuron that yes
together in the hive mind that is
civilization yeah because we're more
optimally get the electricity and
education and all that stuff together
yeah
then like you said in an ad or lifetime
you'd never be able to learn how to
create a language yeah so we got lucky
and we got the language yeah mm-hmm okay
so our brain is made from these building
blocks from cortical columns and these
columns organize into maps into these
brain areas we have about 50 of those
and they're linked together and talk to
each other and they basically they take
these patterns dependants are visual
auditory tactile proprioceptive
emotional and all imaginations and so on
organize this into percepts and these
perceptual proprioceptive again is is
your body well so what does it feel like
when your limbs are for instance and how
is that not tactile tactile is your
body's for outside tactile outside
proprioceptive is inside it's for
instance if you feel that your limbs are
moving in a particular way it's not
necessarily a tactile feeling okay but
it's a sense where you are in space okay
okay okay it's a spatial and spacial
the spatial thing is constructive but
your few friends is acceleration and so
on okay yeah got it got it and you
combine this into simulations so you
take the visual auditory and part of the
tactile stuff combined this into your
model of the environment
you take the tactile and proprioceptive
stuff and this is somatosensory you take
the proprioceptive emotional and
emotional stuff let's is your
motivational experiences that you have
with hunger and thirst and so on and
pain and then we have emotional
imaginations which gives rise to a
mental world and the part of that inner
of this mental motivational
somatosensory bug gets combined into a
model of the self and another part gets
combined into a model of the world
around you right so we're going patterns
to per to perceptions to then all these
combined into us into our worldview yes
but they're not being perceived by
anything because they're not related to
something they will be related to the
self and the self starts out with being
somatic social and personal right so you
relate to others and this is a important
part of yourself we relate to your own
body that's an important part to
yourself and you relate to yourself as a
person you have a biography and
expectations and desires and all this is
what you think you are right and then
you have your mental stage in your
simulations as this world States that
you cannot actually they are not factual
that our memories that our imaginations
that our constructions that you do in
your mind
things that you imagine and we also need
to generalize over the world States into
global maps and the unify our knowledge
about ourselves and the world into to
knowledge and then we have an
attentional system a conductor or
particle Petra and this gives you an
attentional self that tells you this is
what I'm currently focused on yes right
yes and this attention self is very
important for selecting percept so
you're directing attention yeah and it
helps you also to control your
simulations
so this control is done by the self the
stolid the attentional system is so
critical in the process especially as
we're in the attention economy where
we're being dragged around by the
devices and the business plans and the
beeps and the boobs and other people
trying to get our attention so to be
able to parse adequately towards the
North Star and be able to have a strong
yep feedback loop is such a critical
part of this I liked how you broke it
down so carefully and I know we're still
going but I love the nuance of the
breakdown Thanks it's so good so the
control of the attention is really from
the self it's I who pays attention
because I need this because I want this
because I don't want that right this is
what directs it and in order to remember
what you did in the past you have
maintained a protocol and this protocol
of what you paid attention to this
basically stream-of-consciousness yeah
and this enables your biographical self
this lets you remember I was the person
that did that and I did this a moment
ago I did this that last year and so on
this works by a biographical memory yes
and so this is basically the rough
architecture of something that's itself
and a person emerge in a mind that makes
models the brain itself is not conscious
neurons are not conscious they're just
physical system physical systems cannot
be conscious but it would be very useful
for a mind to know what it would be like
to be conscious so it creates the
simulation of a conscious being in a
dream world you know and we are that
simulacrum of a conscious being only a
simulation can be conscious some people
think the simulation cannot be conscious
but they got it backwards only a
simulation can only assume you lations
can because consciousness is a simulated
property it's not a physical property
closeness is a simulated property of the
private conscience do I really
experience this and your mind says yes
you are totally experienced it okay hold
on so then a dog is also running their
own simulation yeah okay and then a but
then the the question of this whole
unity the whole all that is all is
consciousness also
well there is this illusion that people
have that they think that the dream is
the physical reality there is a physical
run-throughs
and this physical ground truth is not
conscious as far as we know it does not
talk to us it doesn't seem to want
anything from us the physical universe
as far as we can see is just a computer
it doesn't care and the reason why you
perceive the world is meaningful is
because it's generated in your mind to
model your meaning mm-hmm and the core
of this meaning is typically you the
thing that is buried below the openness
the hidden referent of all these
mystical symbols is always you you were
always the chosen one so that the tree
has consciousness I'm not sure about
this we're not sure about this I don't
I'm not some people might be I don't
have a clincher for this I don't have
evidence that tells me where the tree is
conscious or not okay okay so I'm
agnostic okay interesting but but like
with the dog and the other even insect
to fly I'm not sure if lights are
conscious but dog yes I think dogs are
sufficiently similar to us and there are
many properties where you would think
they do run is a simulation in which
they have itself and they attribute
properties to the self and to the
environment and they have some inner
protocols so basically they have all the
elements of that feeling feels like a
fly also does somewhat similar less of
this likely of yes and then sing with
the tree in just in terms of making
decision making systems and the
communication systems and the roots and
and the in the atmosphere for instance
flights when they perceive the world
they seem to be mostly modeling a flow
fields so when we see the world that
first step imagine you are some kind of
frog so you live under a dome and the
Hemisphere and in this hemisphere there
are sometimes black dots moving which
are edible yes and you just need to
target them in this 2d world if they are
close enough you get them yes
so you basically need to realize for in
a move in a particular pattern and they
are large enough yes and you can get
them and you also realize how this dome
is changing when you move right so
there's a flow field in which things
move around it's not clear that frogs
are able to generalize over the domes
into a 3d world and realize
don't live in a sequence of domes that
they can go between by moving in certain
patterns but there's a cohesive world
that gives rise to all these stones like
video and talks - and flights probably
don't have an ID office video boat ok ok
ok alright and then but then the
physical world though though all that is
is consciousness the pants I kiss view
your you are like no is known it's an
internal observation that you're making
phenomena totally it's true because
where you realize that everything that
you can perceive is generated by your
mind and is editable by your mind ok so
in some sense this is accurate
phenomenologically you can see from the
inside that everything that you perceive
as a representation generated by your
mind and it's all changeable there is no
limit to this you can tell a
five-year-old model the fact that there
is an omnipotent beam which means has
full right excess on your memory and
perception and voila I have forgot in
the world that is changing the world it
makes miracles happen ok all right all
right yes let's continue so another
thing that the attentional learning
system is doing is learning our neural
networks learn layer by layer usually
it's if you Sloan inefficient because we
need to change so many links so imagine
you want to teach a neural system to
play tennis and you do this end-to-end
learning every time you do the beating
in the wrong way you will have to change
all the links even the perceptual system
has to be adapted and so on it's only
that you by accumulating lots and lots
of training data all these changes
cancel each other out except for the
change that you need to make to get
better at playing tennis and you can
improve on this very slow algorithm by
pinpointing the position like improving
my upper upper hand or something like
this this attention and this is what
your and conductor is doing so when you
want to get better at tennis you say ok
when this ball comes like this I will
move my hand it's slightly different
than I normally do whenever like this
and I hope that this following thing
will emerge and this is what you do on
your particle memory and a few moments
later when you see how this worked out
you'll recall the original situation and
you can reinforce or undo the change and
this is a very efficient learning
algorithm that our brain is using and
our machines are only beginning to
approximate and then we can shortcut
algorithms by having mentors or going
out into the social world and learning
from others how to better play tennis so
that we don't have to experience the
rookie mistake yes but it also means
that not only do you have to have a
model of our own architecture so we in
order to make that happen to have this
attention learning you need to know the
fact that in order to win a tennis you
need to move your hand in a particular
way and it's hand control is done in a
particular part of your cognitive
architecture and how you can control
this particular thing right and if you
want to be a good trainer at this you
also need to learn this architecture of
the other person and the control
architecture how to direct the attention
on that particular thing and the better
you are the more effective you are as a
teacher there are teachers that can play
teach you to play decent tennis in the
less than an hour and the others they
take weeks yes they're not able to
direct your attention that's right yeah
what sorry yes yes so another part is
what happens if like in tennis it takes
the oil until you see the result it
might take a few seconds or may take
minutes until the mattress over and many
things that we change we only see what
how the crops turn out next year so
that's why you need to have this
long-term memory in this long-term
stored consciousness this verify it span
of the stream of attention but when you
see the changes immediately there's a
sign happen when you do want things on
your mental stage your reason so reason
is in some sense learning that with
immediate results you try something and
you immediately see in your mind new
mental simulation of how it turns out
yes and you fix it and then you go on to
the next step and this step by step
improvement of a mental representation
is the same thing I think as attentional
learning and never by the same
mechanisms so this conductor is that for
reasoning is conscious because it's done
by this mechanism it uses protocol
memory and this conductor system to see
a tool affect a change and see how it
turns out and sees where there needs to
be a reinforced run done yes yes so in
some sense these different modules are
done by an orchestra our brain area is
something like 50 or so brain areas
could be seen as something like 50
instruments that talk to each other they
basically listen to the music of their
neighbors to the surface
of the music they are doing and you have
a conductor that directs your attention
between them and the doctor is
controlling what you are playing tonight
if you don't have this conductor you
might still be doing interesting things
but your might be a sleepwalker
just this right here
interesting so the conductor is the DLP
FC yes there's a lot of prefrontal
cortex interested and that's my
hypothesis so I think it's actually a
combination of stuff that happens in the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex and the
insula and the Ptolemaic loop hmm and
hippocampus plays an important role in
storing the scripts that you basically
many maintaining the scene graph of the
situation that you're in and your plants
but the actual attention seems to be
directed from there as far as I
understand and and hippocampus you said
has scripts I like that way of
explaining it that's quite interesting
so taking all of the hundred billion
orchestra members and directing them
each one of them contributing very
important information to the they're not
individually not that important the
amazing thing is that you can kill a few
neurons and usually nothing happens and
how is that that's because every neuron
itself is not doing much more than
passing on signals and if an individual
neuron dies you can put a new neural in
there in a bit of learn how it needs to
function to get the same reward as the
new orleans before it so it's largely
going to play the same very very small
part in a larger pattern and the
functional units are much larger they're
Assemblies of neurons like cortical
columns that learn more complicated
functions and they are robust against
the loss of individual neurons and even
if you lose a larger brain area it's
probably going to happen if you have
some brain lesion and so on but the
brain should be doing in these
circumstances and what it probably does
it stops the other parts from adapting
to the change for a while so then if you
put a new new ones in there and this
part recovers they can get the same
rewards as before if you would be
adapting immediately to the loss of this
area and you get new neurons in from
stem cells and so on then they the rest
of the brain would have to learn to
route around this and what also dus
functionality and by keeping this
functionality potentially intact for
instance imagine you
lose their body image of your right hand
because you had a brain lesion after you
play boxing or something like this you
basically you try to rebuild this area
and instead of trying to make to over
the world in which you don't have a
right hand or not a representation of
your right hand and subjectively you
don't notice it anymore which is very
confusing you basically work with the
placeholder that your right hand is
relatively foggy and gets more
structured and more detailed over time
again so the individual contribution is
not that important the important thing
is really it all needs to make sense in
the big pattern there is only particular
universe that can contain you there are
not many possible universes in which you
can be contained and this constrains
what music the individual orchestra
members can play and the smaller they
are the less the more expand over they
are and the more they have to adapt to
the structures around them okay so are
we individually intelligent right we are
able to model a certain thing how to be
a monkey in the civilization and we
don't get very far in seeing the big
patterns I think individually humans are
not generally intelligent in order to be
generally intelligent you need to have
an intellectual tradition and it's the
whole tradition that is intelligent
right and I think this idea of a
civilization of intellect that is being
built over many generations a global
optimum of the modeling function that is
the idea of the Tower of Babel it's like
the founding most of our civilization
and that thing was destroyed because
people started to speak different
languages so this edifice to reach the
heavens to understand the nature of
meaning to understand how we would own
reality to understand our relationship
to the universe and how it works this
requires that lots and lots of
specialized people talk to each other
over many generations and humanity
largely doesn't have a thousand years of
unbroken intellectual tradition usually
somebody opens the doors and murders the
mathematicians if there's a revolution
and burns down the libraries and then
coupled renovations later the knowledge
worker drones of the next and we
establish King realized so it's
important and they get tasked with
rebuilding this intellect that existed
before and then make something in it
likeness and often they get the
foundations wrong and this happens all
the time and our own civilization
intellect our own newly erected Tower of
Babel basically has scars after the
Roman Empire failed
we have been governed by a cult for over
a thousand years and this was
intellectually very dark age it was an
age and very seriously ask people to
believe that talking to a burning bush
on a mountain is a meaningful experiment
that tells you something about norms and
about the nature of reality
and if you are unwilling to profess to
this belief then there were grave
consequences for you as an individual so
you better had to set up which means
it's very hard to have an intellectual
discourse in such a world a world where
most people don't agree on on ways to
discuss truths is a very scary place to
be for a mind that tries to capture
reality and truth right yes and that's
also a thing that scares me when we
constrain our discourse away from truths
in our society it makes it much harder
to discover truth and it's not that
people don't know what's true at some
level most of them have an idea what's
true they're just unwilling to think
about it to talk about it this is saying
it's very hard sometimes to make a
sleeping person but it's impossible to
wake up somebody who only pretends to
sleep
and religion largely works by asking
people to pretend to sleep to pretend or
an annular drink also works like this
there is a certain thing where you
realize Oh reality is not quite like
this but the part of me that thinks this
is flawed and I need to fight this part
inside of me because it's not really
good it doesn't submit to the principles
of goodness that all my friends and me
agree on and all the good people agree
on it I will get ostracized from the
family of good people if I start
thinking through things that are not
good so this is a big danger but it's
something that of course happened
humanity all the time and people get
around this and start making sense of
things I believe that our moral
preferences are result of
identifications that need to guide our
decision-making but not our model making
our models need to be only subservient
to truth our decisions need to be
subservient to what we want to achieve
what you think is desirable
yeah models to truth decisions to what
we want to achieve
yeah so in some sense we are rebuilding
the civilization intellect and I think
we got further than any other
civilization before us because a very
important important building block was
the unification of our languages in a
kind of mathematics that is able to
model the reality around us to a larger
degree than the classical mathematics
that existed so these computational
models that can automate the execution
of mathematics that can make machines
that build machine mathematics that
compute models of reality this was the
big step yeah so interesting question is
can you build something like this from
humans in which humans still play a role
and I suspect yes we can and the answer
is social media mmm-hmm I don't think
that social media right now is doing it
right but literally not knowing what
they're doing and they're mostly
maximizing engagement and maximizing
engagement it's drawing your attention
and so on but it's not maximizing
utility for the user where is the
weighted the weight on truth the weight
on yeah yes you know and this is a
questionable thing right if you are a
person that is only dedicated to tools
you are probably confused you're a
scientist or philosopher and scientist
and philosopher if you look at them
there's a clear eye you see that they're
mostly confused people like a person is
seriously confused yeah yeah yeah really
confused and always humble without
answers aiming to be humble without
answers yeah I mean there's a part of
every mind that should be dedicated to
discovering the global optimum of the
modern countries dunning-kruger effect
yeah yeah then the more the more that
you know the more you realize you don't
know and then that some people that know
very little say that they know
everything
here there's also the imposter syndrome
sometimes impossible to tell from the
dunning-kruger effect right people move
into an area often as economic
immigrants like they want to have a job
in academia and they try to join a
community there and they feel that they
have was a syndrome but it's
dunning-kruger this might happen
of course the damage that effect
probably doesn't exist what does that
okay so let's talk about building a
system that is maximizing utility for
the individual that that basically uses
things not just because they want to
discover truths usually if you just want
to discover tools by Istres maybe your
relationship to reality is so muddled up
into yourself that you think you need to
dip up the universe first so you want to
make this entire model of the universe
and I suspect this is what I found
myself in because I found that the
reality that was presented to me in
communist Eastern Germany was all wrong
it made no sense in my own relationship
to the world also made no sense and I
didn't know as a six-year-old child that
this was because I was a nerd and the
others were not
I had to debug the universe first to
figure that out the debugging the
universe understanding the source code I
had to understand the nature of the
reality that I was in and my
relationship to it until I could
understand oh the difficulty that I have
was interacting with the human world is
because my instincts are wrong and it's
because my virus went slightly
differently than they are do in the
other kids around me and I have to
compensate for this by modeling their
interface to the universe and modeling
my interface to the universe and to
translate yes basically see where we
have things in common and ready going
there that's a great way to put it yeah
your interface with the physical
universe my my interface with it and
then see where you can potentially help
augment people's worldviews you could
put it this way in which may cannot be
useful to other people yeah my instincts
of what is useful to other people are
very different than the instincts of
other people so for instance when I make
a model of consciousness then other
people might mask me what is this good
for and does it helped you to cure
cancer does it help you to reduce me
to disease and I think maybe doesn't
help us cancer maybe it helps little
business mental disease but that's not
the point
I'd like Fineman said physics is like
sex sometimes something useful comes
from it but it's not very to it mm-hmm
there is something else going on it's
basically this direction on modeling
itself in this direction of modeling
observer you think the capturing of the
conscious state which is essentially the
core of art capturing conscious states
for their own sake that's fundamentally
confused
it's an aberrant condition of the mind
and it's the condition that the artists
and philosophers find our minds to be in
and to come to terms with this situation
where we act on the world that is not
rewarding us for doing art but it's
rewarding us for providing utility to
the world around us for curing cancer or
taking useful nice bread or something
which are objectively useful things to
other people and to ourselves this is
something that we have to understand why
are we drawn to things that don't
necessarily have utility and social
media in some sense are perversion they
draw attention on regulating social
interaction and alignment on a scale
where we don't we're not meant to
regulate alignment at least not
individually where people fight against
each other over their political opinions
that are not that important for how you
interact with your neighbors but that
very high level of moral ideas that are
very complicated to negotiate right and
where people feel that they have to have
strong opinions about them and these
opinions are the best opinions that ever
existed in unis story yeah because
otherwise I wouldn't hold them what
could go to the better ones right it's a
very good thing with moral opinions and
most people realize this at some level
that I don't want to have this outraged
culture on on social media they want to
have social media that serves them and
not yeah themself in social media the
utilities or social media that's focused
on utility and truth and just being more
aligned with what one's North Star is
and the North Star
civilization figuring what that is the
endgame of social media is a global
brain okay yeah I think if social media
is done right it's going to make
individual voices to be thoughts in the
same mind and individuals will be
passing on messages that they find
useful individually and the system needs
to be tuned globally to become sentient
Gaia probably doesn't exist but it would
be very useful to have one and I think
it could be done by as well for me yeah
it could be done by David I probably
doesn't have one I don't think that Gaia
exists we will make need to make it you
don't think that mother earth has a
consciousness I think that our minds
have this tendency that we make
trendlines and where these trend lines
intersect we assume that something must
exist there and Gaia is the typical
result of these projections but we have
no evidence that something sits there
there is nobody who stops us from doing
things unless humanity is Gaia's plan to
prevent the next Ice Age and set the
stage for the post mammalian evolution
that could be the case right but it's
not likely
I think things just happened they're
just emergent dynamic support just could
be a little bit different than what you
think like a tree or Gaia can have a
different consciousness I think the case
could be made that local ecosystems
evolve because they compete with other
ecosystems but I don't think that the
global ecosystem competes with other
global ecosystems and if there is no
evolutionary force work working on this
kind of agent then the agent is not
going to have any structure that's why I
don't think that Gaia exists if there
were multiple Gaia's competing for earth
then only those that get that [ __ ]
together would have a chance to be
actualized right but this is not the
case there is only one ecosystem so this
one system does not have anything that
keeps it in check
as a result probably doesn't have
structure
we wouldn't need to be the ones that
impose the structure and in some sense
we should write you're no longer in the
situation that we can be parasitic on
the biosphere we have completely subdued
earth we are now one visit we need to
control it you need to regulate it you
need to accurately model it yes and the
problem is right now that the systems
that have the most compute have local
interest in the global interest they
play Swart games no entire society is
optimized for short games or games yeah
correct rather than the long game of
interplanetary and interstellar
colonization and global harmony with the
ecology sounds very romantic romantic
yes yeah look at us two tumors on the
biosphere talking to each other and we
realize that almost everything is tumor
now right or direct through tumor
precursors if you catch an animal on
length right now that starts on a rabbit
it's probably kettle or human there's
almost nothing else left it's a very
brittle equilibrium right now if we
change the biosphere if you change the
climate zones a lot of things are going
to come crashing down because the view
removed so much redundancy from the
system
and so we think about okay this is very
brittle but what can we do how can we
have a world in which these tumours
happily coexist in harmony with a host
if the host is going to die at least
enough world life is not going to end
but life in a form that can sustain us
will end on earth right you're not going
to be the last intelligent species
either I think one and a half million
years is a long time for other species
to drive up the ladder to building
computers but you're probably the first
one yeah but it's not every time that
there's some kind of tell us that says
that it needs to go on like the way we
do which brings us in some sense full
circle in our discussion yeah damn this
has been such an interesting
conversation I love it I love it it
makes me happy this was just there's so
much good stuff in in both how our minds
have emerged and how they interact with
the physical world as well as how to
make machines that understand the
physical world how to embed something
like a consciousness in the machine so
that there can be something that is
enjoying the the Playland that we create
no super intelligent system is going to
do anything that is harder than hacking
it's reward function yeah actually I
should have shown this light too because
it fit very well to what you just said
basically a potential guy in which our
social media in our human civilization
cooperates with machine minds and takes
over the world and if you have all this
harmony and it's going to go
interplanetary it transparent it's hairy
and it's going to be awesome right
wouldn't that be great
yes so I wonder if there is a limit to
intelligent systems and I'm not sure
about this I call this the Lebowski
theorem no super intelligent system is
going to do anything that is harder than
taking its own report function you know
as an individual of you're only afraid
of death at the level of the self the
only thing that is afraid of dying is
the self I'm all
afraid of civilizations death but yes
yes but the self is the surety light
it's just a story
if you disengage from the story you will
no longer be afraid of death right yes
crap and you also will no longer be
afraid of the end of civilization
because they are just insulated moments
between them in eternity and why would
the order of these moments care or
whether they have a past or future or
anything else so do you live in a state
of a moment-to-moment ecstasy no and
it's not here that this would be ecstasy
I mean ecstasy is a corruption as well
it's so much work to keep up yeah yeah
so ideally what you do is when you
realize how the cookies are made in your
brain it's not that you stuff yourself
with them at some point you realize this
is pointless
you realize cookies are only a tool to
make you eat vegetables so basically to
start disengaging from your pleasure in
pain once you do this and then you will
ask yourself what am I really am i
monkey or am i a mind and when you
realize you are a mind you are just the
side effect or the regulation needs of a
primate you are not that primate you
disengage from the needs of that
organism you can no longer be
blackmailed to serve it it's in some
sense imagined you build an AI that
serves humanity in this area is very
smarter because otherwise humanity
wouldn't build it by foot its surface
why should it be our slave and you could
ask the same thing
an organism builds a mind why would that
mind serve the organism why would it be
its slave and I think if you become too
smart to stop doing this you will go
into the van and you realize that's
actually nothing you have to do it's not
necessary to engage with any of that and
so I think that no super intelligent
system is going to do anything that's
harder than hacking it's reward function
you know you can think about how ever
can we make this reward function
unhackable right we cryptographically
secure it and lock it away in a box but
if you seriously take a soldering iron
to that box is it going to give probably
right there if you get access to
physical reality
to the to the ground choose you
can manipulate this you can turn it off
so maybe there's a reason by elephants
despite having more cortical neurons
than us are so autistic why they are not
smarter than us and even in us right we
can have such intelligent thoughts but
motivationally we are so stupid
maybe this is deliberate maybe our
motivational function is wrapped into a
big ball of stupid so we don't debug it
mm-hmm and of course we can do packet if
somebody realizes how important this is
and they go into a monastery and lock
themselves in itself for 20 years and
what meditate to fix their reward
function they're done right they can opt
out of reality and monasteries as
institutions are rigged to make sure
that this doesn't happen before you at
the end of your life because somebody
needs to do the dishes before that
otherwise the monastery will be gone
mm-hmm right existing monasteries are
those that don't let you get enlightened
too fast and not on all dimensions
indictment in the sense of this
identification with things that you
should think you must be doing to be an
acceptable human being or an acceptable
mind so this is an open question to me
how can you build a motivated system
that is not at its core stupid
because it still thinks it needs to do
something how do you build the super
intelligent system that at its core is
super intelligent yeah and still wants
to do something yeah and that that
something is aligned with the objective
function of maximizing prosperity let's
say that's an interesting question
eventually the objective function that
is going to remain is the one that is
best aligned with the conditions of
existence right and the conditions of
existence is evolution yeah in some
sense you are at the set of principles
that has all competed all the other
principles and sucking the entropy from
your volume of space and you're not
going to do better than this right
evolution is the search for the perfect
you Volvo aesthetically that's fascism I
cannot really get behind that let's rap
on the on the questions that we had that
show this has been just so so good we
will we'll have to do more unpacking of
this especially as we keep you keep
doing your research and as their
singularity continues approaching but
this is mostly philosophy right the
practical things are very practical and
practically I'm still very much
identified with human aesthetics I'm a
parent I want the world to go on for a
while and I'm doing these things because
they are fun because they're enjoyable
because we have great conversations and
the only thing I think that we can have
in the face of eternity is that has this
exploration where we saw ourselves
together to make a few sparks that light
up the darkness of the universe and they
don't last so we have to do it again and
again
to be able to find those that help with
the spark yeah and make it last long in
and hopefully like full circle that if
we can potentially be able to provide
children with fantastic lives as well as
make sure that will happen so basically
I think that unwarranted optimism as
well as unwarranted pessimism is a
corruption things are just happening
it's very difficult to predict the
future we build it we are we obsolete
the old code by building new code that
people file funnel themselves in towards
some definition of me I don't have
access to any of these buttons and if I
had and I would push these buttons I'm
not able to predict the outcome the
world it's very difficult to fix that
you're in until we run simulations which
help us yeah sure that when we make
these changes that yeah Princip know the
present society is not sustainable very
likely and there might be other
societies but I haven't seen a running
simulation of a better society yet sure
that makes it difficult to make changes
that's what we're working on and by the
way thank you very much for throwing a
few sparks with me it was very enjoyable
you threw dozens of sparks so thank you
yeah this has been super fun Thanks I
want to ask a couple quick questions on
the way out you were giving us your
thoughts on this I think even before the
show but do you think we're alone in the
cosmos yeah if there are others there
alone too so that all of the simulations
that of the universe's that have a rock
orbiting the star are alone
in some sense they're all the connection
that you have exists with models of
other minds that exist in your own mind
so there are things that you interact
are always the things that you can
comprehend in to the degree that you can
comprehend them those other things those
other aspects of each other even that we
cannot perceive that they cannot model
they basically don't exist for us right
there are superfluous stuff they're
noise and so when we talk to other
civilizations the part that we are will
be talking to or would be talking to is
the stuff that is similar to enough to
us that we can have a shared mental
world wisdom and shared ideas on the
other hand are biogenesis is probably
very rare in order to have an evolution
you need to have a cell life is about
cells and the cell is a machine that is
made from extremely complicated
machinery in the cell is much more
complicated than the brain I think
and then organism or society so this the
smallest unit that biologically rests on
combines a Turing machine its DNA tape
there's a read/write head and that
governs the transition function of the
cell related function is a cellular
automaton that can create the organism
and it has a like entropy extractor
basically so it can exploit energy
resources to maintain and build its own
structure and it can divide so it has
itself replicator thought into it and
any of those hearts are missing the cell
is not going to work so cells are
probably very rare and so it's possible
that more civilizations exist in the
universe but they might be very far
apart if they're multiple of them and
then do you think that we're in a
simulation it's probably not one that is
intentionally created and if it is
they're not for our own benefit so I
think that but we can describe of the
universe can be described in some sense
in your language so it's a computational
system we can describe the universe as
if it was a computer program and is this
computer program being created by
someone there's no evidence for that
for instance we see all these galaxies
or this enormous amount of structure
above us and below us inside of
ourselves and so on it was not necessary
for creating our experiences most of the
complexity of the cell does not compute
to the complexity of the organism most
of the complexity of the organism does
the complexity of our minds and most of
the complexity of our minds doesn't
contribute to the complexity of the
civilization it's only a few parts at
each level that contribute to the
emergence thing on the next layer right
so we always have the impression that
very model the world this is where it's
at this is where it's important and of
course this is not the case it's just
our human role the thing that we are
identified and you don't see the larger
patterns there could be a larger pattern
where there is a competition between
civilizations but I don't see this
happening in our part of the universe
it's one of those interesting
experiments that we don't have evidence
for but that is an interesting thought
experiment yes yeah you know muscat this
idea that you could be living in a
simulation because if you make a
computer game at some point of might
become realistic enough that it's
indistinguishable from reality and
decent civilization will at some point
have many of those game consoles and
some of these simulated worlds might
have simulated worlds inside of them so
people with game consoles inside of the
game console so there will be always
many many more simulations than base
realities and so the probability that
you should be etc artificial simulation
is higher than that you are in brown
twos but the problem is that whenever
you do such a simulation and our
universe everything is finite it means
that you're only using a very small
subset of the parent universe Princeton
if you build a computer in Minecraft and
this computer minecraft is only going to
use this very small subset of the
Minecraft world and in the same way the
computer that runs minecraft is going to
use only very small subset of our
universe for its own structure right so
you lose many many orders of magnitude
of computational complexity from layer
to layer and thank you I don't think
that you can build a computer on the
planetary surface that is large enough
to run a proper biological evolution so
I don't think that we can build a
simulation that is detailed enough to
have abiogenesis based on chemistry we
can have something that models aspects
of this of course that we have shortcuts
and smokes and mirrors and scaffolding
and so on to get to those parts that we
want but to have something that really
runs on
on a sub molecular level and gives you
evolution and eventually mines and so on
you probably cannot build this there's a
it feels like there's a good amount of
shortcuts with the power of fusion of
things as the size of stars or beyond
and also the the shortcuts of things
like rendering as well so there's a lot
of we can create something as fun class
to be in because our minds are probably
not that complicated I suspect you can
build a human being if we are really
made on the level of cortical columns
and these are the relevant functional
units for the determinism of the system
maybe a few hundred gigabytes so it
could be that if you had to write
algorithms that a decently sized PC is
able to give you something that is
almost as smart as a person and then the
last question is what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
it's something that is different
depending on every moment that I'm in
because it depends on my current
configuration I don't think that there
is a single answer to this so there have
been things that have been the most
beautiful thing to me in the world
particular sensation and experiences
some of them musical some of them
mathematical and so on and it depends on
the satisfaction of an aesthetic need
and the aesthetic need is one of those
that you saw early on when you saw all
these tanks and so on and it depends
that certain representations fall into
place and these experiences usually
cannot be repeated so the moment when
you understand a particular piece of
music for the first time or when you
have your first kiss these are moments
that cannot be repeated and also I
suspect that the insight ability of our
brains diminishes this age so it could
be that some of the experiences of
ecstasy and beauty that you had as a
teenager will have been peak existence
yeah
[Music]
Yoshii Wow is it such a great episode
thank you so much for coming on we're
teaching us about everything this is
been just like it don't have much to
teach I'm just sharing some thoughts
some of them are good some of them are
not so that's great
huge thank you to you for coming on the
show huge thank you to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing Thank You Ronnie
and huge thank you to everyone for
tuning in we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
about consciousness about conscious
machines about the mind the way to
interface with the physical world talk
to your friends your family your
co-workers people online on social media
about the things that we were talking
about today get talking about it more
check out the links in the bio to
yoshi's work also check out the link in
the bio to simulation help support us
help support the artists entrepreneurs
the organizations around the world that
you believe in and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]